the Joe Rogan experience there's another
question okay let's say Donald Trump
just said you said I'm gonna [ __ ]
make an announcement we're gonna have
one Comedy Tour in just one and it they
wanted to put you guys in the comedy
tour and Trump said would you do it
would you jump on into that I know I
don't do anything for anybody like that
no no I'm not doing these shows for no
no like as as the first shows this is
gonna break down the barriers for comedy
shows Donald Trump need to be given
freedom that we were used to a concert
right now
no he need to allow you Donald Trump
said I'm gonna allow you this one tour
full stadiums one tour Joe's not in are
you able to breathe underwater are you
in are you in yeah men will mean Brandon
I can do it I can I bring my swim in it
look out overnight look up Brian
Donald Trump approve twice if you guys
can fill stadiums how crazy would that
be hey bro what's up is there a problem
that's [ __ ] electrical is Showtime
like your pizzeria work your tank top
secret pizzeria worker tank your old
navy masters division Tov I was in my
own private gym wearing a tank top and I
was embarrassed myself
Junior no Junior
what you're changing the subject for
sure fun no I thought for sure you guys
followed him no you should do honors the
ground followed is so gangster the
shitty posted today oh my he throws gun
dude he's a beast he's a [ __ ] beast
on the Internet holy [ __ ] follow follow
dog he saw something crazy about Joe
Biden like some meme Joe Bailon
after a while pedophiles see you later
alligator
yeah it was hard yeah that's hard I see
a model phone okay but that's a crazy
thing like that's savage savage it's
crazy that we're at this point where we
were Tom's with Bridget fantasy
yesterday and she was talking about this
congresswoman was it what does she do
representative the lady who said [ __ ]
Trump or [ __ ] Elon Musk's brother
Thomas [ __ ] you [ __ ] she said
what she like should say so she just
went with like the crazy statement but
what we found fascinating yesterday we
were talking we were like imagine at any
other time people saying something like
that okay no one is ever safe [ __ ]
Ronald Reagan I can't do that dude would
say no congressperson or senator or
representative what no representative
would ever get on a public forum like
Twitter never and right [ __ ] you know
but when you have the fake screen media
for the last three years trying to be
mainstream it's fake people trying to
reinvent themselves show with new
nicknames so if the fake stream media
decided to attack you and smear you and
[ __ ] connect you with all the that's
what's going on we all just be friends
dude I'm just stating fact it's kind of
progressive right hey hey boys how long
before the store and the improv and
factory fake stream media has been
crushing Donald Trump trying to ruin his
life and the lives of his family since
day one of course he's like this I know
people they're like oh I hate him why
does he have to be such an [ __ ] he's
such an [ __ ] Mike dude they're trying
to ruin him on a daily basis you put on
every day I take a [ __ ] I put on my
phone and there's a headline Trump is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
every [ __ ] day I take a [ __ ]
drop a [ __ ] [ __ ] every day you're
shouting to him we can't do it like this
you're talking to okay I get it in a
people
no we can't [ __ ] do anything we're
just sitting here hearing you yelling
about Trump I want to watch some skating
practice it's your opinion that's a fact
what I just said okay I said facts I bet
your spirit but I think you're coming in
hard in the paint and I'm feeling a
little sensitive okay you're still
little blue so I'm an inch by inch hey
someone answer my question right now
everybody shout a little [ __ ] passion
about I'm in the world in the world
order right now
[Applause]